for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
next up is beta decay specifically beta
minus decay okay I put a little note
here there are three types of beta decay
which I've actually mentioned in the
intro way to minus decay which is what
this video is about and then positron
emission or beta pause beta plus
emission and electron capture they're
all classified under beta decay but
whenever someone or a practice problem
or a text book mentions just beta decay
they're usually talking about this one
beta minus decay all right so a beta
particle is represented like this mass
number of 0 and z of negative one with
little beta and sometimes it has the
beta minus and what it is it's just an
electron okay so it can be represented
like this with a negative one down here
zero up top negative one down here with
0 12 with an e or an e- so i'm going to
use this one that's the one i like to
use i like to use the one with the
negative charge here first of all I like
to put the beta because it's beta decay
remind you that it's beta decay also the
negative up there helps me remember that
it's beta minus decay it's just another
reminder a beta minus particle is also
called a negatron negatron and you might
think isn't that kind of the opposite of
a positron that actually is the case
they are antiparticles of each other
we'll talk about that a little bit more
in positron emission we won't go into
details will just mention it again so
let's do an example we have carbon 14
here as the parent we have the a equal
to 14 Z equal to 6 the N is thus equal
to 14-6 which will be 8 ok it's kind of
an ugly let's try that again it's a
little bit better ok so when this thing
emits a beta particle
the VA up here is 0 right Izzy down here
is negative 1 so what goes in for the
daughter if the a is on both sides left
and right need to be exactly the same or
the total a and total Z's need to be the
same on both sides so if the VA here is
already 0 and the overall right side
needs to be 14 then it remains 14 and if
it was six initially and now I've got
this negative 1 hear something needs to
go here well I'll put a 7 because 7
minus 1 will equal 6 so now what's the
identity of this daughter it's going to
be nitrogen if you look on again just a
periodic table you look for an atomic
number of 7 you find that region so
let's find the ends here what is the end
here here there are no ends because they
would contribute to the mass number so
there's none there right here there's
14-7 sailors 7 neutrons there so what
happened to all these values here the a
stays the same a stays the same what
happens is e we see that the Z goes from
six to seven so the Z increases by one
what happens to the N the N decreases by
1 ok so what happened here is kind of
weird ok let's think about what's going
on or why beta minus decay actually
occurs beta minus decay occurs when
there are too many neutrons in the
nucleus too many neutrons in the nucleus
too many neutrons so what happens is a
neutron is converted into a proton and
an electron which are both which the
electron is actually the beta particle
that's emitted so here I wrote that here
as a neutron being converted into a
proton plus an electron ok so this
Neutron is decreased by one here gets
turned into this proton as well as an
electron right and that electron is that
beta part
here that is emitted okay so you can
actually write these as 10 here 1 1 here
and 0 negative 1 for those right neutron
has a mass number of one note protons
right or is math atomic number of zero
proton Z of 1 a of one electron we just
saw with the beta particle that is the
beta bar go there right this is this
right so this occurs in beta minus decay
because beta minus decay occurs when
there are too many neutrons so that was
a way that that is solved is that
neutron is converted into a proton and
an electron the proton remains in the
daughter right to give that new element
and the the electron is the beta
particle that flies out of this nucleus
ok so this electron is not an electron
from outside of the nucleus this is a
result of the conversion of a neutron
into a proton electron this electron
will just fly out fly out of the nucleus
okay so that's pretty much beta minus
decay now the general form is shown like
this based on based on this what I wrote
here in green the a stays the same and
the Z actually increases by one so it's
shown like this
okay there we go there's the general
form with little cloudy box thingy
around it and that wraps up this video I
hope that was helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying